* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Ich will einfach
mein Leben auf die Reihe kriegen.
Aber meine Angst ist eben,
dass ich nicht genug bin
für die Sachen, die ich tun muss,
dass ich nicht gut genug bin -
keine Ahnung - für meine Freunde,
nicht gut genug bin für die Schule.
Deine Medikamente.
Was wäre das Ziel
eines Aufenthaltes?
Ich möchte,
dass einfach alles mal runterfährt.
Ich merke selbst, ich bin ...
Entschuldigung.
Es geht nicht mehr, so quasi.
Ich weiss, wenn ich einfach
immer damit weitermache,
dann fühle ich mich nicht wohl oder
ich fühle mich einfach nie wohl.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Bis vor Kurzem wäre es
für Emils Eltern undenkbar gewesen,
ihn allein zu lassen.
Zu gross war die Angst,
er könne sich etwas antun.
Dass sie mir vertrauen,
ist schon toll.
Ich versuche, dass es
nicht ganz im Chaos versinkt.
Ich glaub schon,
dass ich das hinkriege,
ohne das Haus abzufackeln.
Früher habe ich mir
immer ein Herz aufgemalt.
Es bedeutet Liebe, weil ich
Liebe etwas mega Wichtiges finde.
Und jetzt stehe ich völlig auf
das Universum, das ist megaspannend.
Wie viele Sterne
gibt es im Universum?
Und wie viele Galaxien?
Und wie funktioniert ihre Symbiose?
Ausserhalb seines Elternhauses
fühlte sich Emil
lange unverstanden und einsam.
Sein seelisches Leid behielt er
für sich, bis zum Zusammenbruch.
Die Geschichte des 14,5-jährigen Emil
ist kein Einzelfall.
Immer mehr Jugendliche
geraten unter Druck,
nehmen psychiatrische
und psychologische Hilfe an.
Ich war immer etwas bunter, etwas
lauter und ein bisschen zu viel.
Der kleine Bub,
der ziemlich viele Fragen stellt
und es leicht schafft, Erwachsene
in den Wahnsinn zu treiben.
Mein Leben
wäre schon einfacher gewesen,
wenn ich normal gewesen wäre,
der Norm entsprochen hätte.
Ich war immer der etwas Spezielle.
Ich habe mich sehr oft
einfach unzulänglich gefühlt.
Dass ich zu wenig bin oder zu
wenig gut für die Schule, zu dumm.
Ich habe es für mich behalten,
dass es mir nicht gut geht
und dass ich mich
nicht reinpassend fühle.
Sehr viele Leute
haben sich von mir abgewendet,
weil sie dachten:
"Oh, der komische Emil."
"Was ist mit ihm los?
Was läuft bei dem falsch?"
Sehr viele Leute
haben sich von mir abgewendet.
Das hat es eigentlich
noch schlimmer gemacht.
Ich habe mich
bereits vorher alleine gefühlt,
aber dann war ich wirklich alleine.
Das war megaschlimm für mich.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Es gab wirklich Mobbingkreise,
in denen ich rumgeschubst wurde.
Ich musste einmal im Spital eine
Platzwunde am Kopf kleben lassen.
Alle waren dabei. Es war das,
was die Leute wirklich vereint hat:
Emil fertigmachen.
Und niemand hat dir geholfen?
Niemand,
von dem ich es gemerkt hätte.
Ja, es war wirklich so,
dass ich morgens Angst hatte,
in die Schule zu gehen,
dass es mir schlecht gewesen war,
dass ich erbrochen habe, aus Stress
und Angst vor diesen Menschen.
Ich ging
immer seltener in die Schule.
Das war auch die Zeit,
in der ich begonnen habe,
mich selbst zu verletzen,
und voll ins Loch gefallen bin.
Ich dachte:
"He, was ist los mit dir?"
"Was läuft mit dir falsch?"
Andererseits gibt es mir in diesem
Moment einfach auch Erleichterung.
Man spürt wieder, dass man da ist:
"He, ich bin ein Lebewesen,
ich bin verletzbar."
"Ich blute, ich bin ein Lebewesen."
"Ich weiss, dass ich lebe,
dass ich jemand bin."
Ja.
* Sanfte Klaviermelodie *
(Bene) Meine Familie
hat nichts geahnt,
auch meine Freunde nicht,
weil ich immer so gewirkt habe,
als ob ich mein Leben
voll im Griff hätte.
Egal welche Umstände,
ich war immer ein glückliches Kind.
Und dann plötzlich diese Gefühle von
Unglück, die aus mir herauskamen.
Und ich wusste nicht,
wie ich sie steuern,
was ich mit ihnen anfangen sollte.
Panikattacken, die von innen
heraus kamen, alles musste raus.
Ich verstand es nicht
und fühlte mich so unwohl.
So ein Tief wie damals
hatte ich noch nie erlebt.
Jeden Morgen
rauchte ich vor dem Zug eine.
Und jedes Mal überlegte ich mir,
ob ich vor den Zug springen soll.
Das Einzige, was mich wirklich
davon abhielt, war der Gedanke:
"Was würde geschehen,
wenn es nicht klappte?"
Ich habe bemerkt,
dass mir die Mutter gefehlt hat,
die Nähe zum Vater gefehlt hat,
weil er so viel arbeiten musste.
Und auch in der Schule
hatte ich Probleme.
Dann noch,
dass die Pubertät hinzukam.
Ich habe mich äusserlich und
innerlich nicht schön gefühlt,
und einfach ungeliebt von allen,
v.a. auch von mir selbst.
Das war der grösste Grund,
weshalb ich dann ...
... in ein solches Loch
gefallen bin.
Beni konnte seine Krise
nicht länger verbergen.
In seiner Verzweiflung
geriet er in eine Essstörung.
Mehrere Zusammenbrüche folgten.
Seine Lehrerin unterstützte ihn
beim Gang zur Schulpsychologin
und zur ambulanten Therapie.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Benis Vater
war für einen attraktiven Job
mit den vier Kindern
nach Zürich gezogen.
Nachdem sich die Eltern
getrennt hatten,
erhielt der Vater das alleinige
Sorgerecht für die Kinder.
Beim Umzug von Australien in die
Schweiz war Beni acht Jahre alt.
Da gibt es eines
mit mir und meinen Eltern.
Das ist eines
aus meiner frühen Kindheit,
als sie noch verheiratet waren
und es noch ganz lustig hatten.
Du bist eigentlich mehr oder weniger
ohne Mutter aufgewachsen.
Wie war das für dich rückblickend?
Rückblickend ist es voll okay,
aber damals war es nicht okay.
Damals habe ich es
nicht ganz verstanden,
weshalb sie plötzlich weg war.
Aber jetzt
komme ich voll damit klar.
Es hat mich auch als Mensch geprägt.
und zum Menschen gemacht,
der ich heute bin.
Inwiefern?
So unabhängig und so zielbewusst.
Nicht abhängig von anderen Menschen,
weil ich eben immer
alles selbst gelernt habe.
* Bene intoniert einen
selbst geschriebenen Popsong. *
# The only way to be free
is to get rid of who you are.
Auch das Klavierspiel
brachte sich Beni selbst bei.
Dieses Lied
komponierte er als Maturaarbeit.
Ein Wendepunkt in seinem Leben.
#  ... then you will never
get a hold on me.
Es war ein Zeichen an meinen Vater,
dass ich erwachsen bin.
Bei der Aufführung
zu meiner Maturaarbeit sagte er mir,
dass er stolz sei,
dass ich wirklich ein Talent hätte.
Nach all den Jahren,
in denen er mir gesagt hat,
dass ich nicht singen könne,
sagte er endlich,
dass ich damit
etwas auf die Reihe bringen könne.
Zwei Wochen danach ist er gestorben.
Deshalb ist dieses Lied für mich
auch so viel mehr als nur ein Lied.
# That I can be alone,
I can be alone.
# I don't need you
to tell me I'm wrong.
# I can be alone. I can be alone.
# I don't need you
to tell me I'm wrong.
# Now leave me alone!
# Please leave me alone.
# Fuck off! Get out of my head.
Beni war 17, als sein Vater starb.
Seither lebt er allein
in dieser Fünfzimmerwohnung.
Die älteren Geschwister waren
schon vor längerer Zeit ausgezogen.
Die bereits gewonnene Unabhängigkeit
wurde zur Pflicht.
Wenn ich spätabends
nach Hause komme, merke ich,
wie dunkel und leer es ist,
dann fühle ich mich auch leer.
Und dann kann es
auch schon vorkommen,
dass ich einfach weinen muss.
Oder einfach meinen Vater vermisse.
Oder in diesem Moment
einfach nicht gerne allein wäre.
Doch dann kann ich meinem Bruder,
meiner Schwester schreiben,
und dann klärt sich
eigentlich alles wieder.
Einzig das Aufstehen morgens
finde ich am Alleinwohnen schwierig.
Einmal aufgestanden - super,
aber aus dem Bett zu kommen,
ohne dass mich der Vater anschreit,
ich solle aufstehen,
ist schon etwas schwierig.
Das ist ein Foto der ganzen Familie,
alle vier Kinder:
Das ist Seren, der Älteste,
Kia, meine Schwester,
Aneiron, mein Bruder,
und ich, das Baby.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Jugendpsychiatrischer Notfalldienst
des Kantons Zürich.
Wie damals Beni und Emil
suchen hier jährlich
über 600 Kinder und Jugendliche
Soforthilfe.
Ich hörte, du hättest Gedanken,
dass du nicht mehr leben möchtest?
Habe ich das richtig verstanden?
- Ja.
Hast du dir schon mal selbst weh-
getan? Mit dem Kopf gegen die Wand?
Ich habe mich schon mal so,
so und so geschlagen.
Ich habe mich geschlagen und einmal
sogar gegen die Wand geschlagen.
Wenn ich einen Fehler mache, einen
einzigen Fehler, nur einen einzigen,
dann werde ich sofort wütend
auf mich und sage: "Ich bin dumm."
Oder wenn ich mal drei Fehler
gemacht habe, sage ich z.B.:
"Ich bin der Schlechteste
auf dem ganzen Planeten
oder im ganzen Universum."
Ist der Gedanke, nicht mehr
leben zu wollen, für Sie ganz neu?
Nein, das hat mir
immer Angst gemacht.
Darum wollte ich
diesen Schritt unternehmen.
Wie würdest du es machen?
In einen Vulkan fallen.
Mich mit einer Pistole erschiessen,
mit einem Messer erstechen oder so.
Die Herausforderung im Notfall ist,
nicht zu viel zu machen,
nicht zu überreagieren.
Und auf der anderen Seite
auch nicht etwas zu verpassen.
Wenn jetzt ein Kind sagt,
es wolle nicht mehr leben,
es wolle sich das Leben nehmen,
sind wir auch dort im Spannungsfeld:
Sofort in die Klinik einweisen?
Auch eine Klinikeinweisung
ist ein traumatisches Erlebnis.
Man kann nicht immer
auf 100%ige Sicherheit gehen.
In dieser Stunde oder in 1 1/2 Std.
mit dem Kind herauszufinden:
Wann ist der Zeitpunkt gekommen?
Wann geht es nicht mehr ambulant,
also zu Hause?
Wann muss man das Kind
vor sich selbst schützen?
In seltenen Fällen: Wann muss man
das Kind vor der Familie, der Schule
oder vor Mobbing in der Schule
schützen? Immer diese Güterabwägung.
Bei diesem Kind konnten wir sagen,
dass wir keine Angst haben,
dass es von seinen Suizidgedanken
in die Handlung geht.
Es hatte keine konkreten Pläne.
Für eine Mutter,
die nie damit konfrontiert war,
ist es eine wahnsinnig
schwierige Entscheidung.
Wenn der Fachexperte
die Sicherheit geben kann,
kann das schon sehr wertvoll sein.
Aber in 45 Min.
können wir keine komplexe
diagnostische Abklärung machen.
Wir löschen Feuer.
Wir sind die Feuerwehrmänner,
die das Feuer löschen
und eine Risikobeurteilung machen:
"Kann man in diesem Haus
noch wohnen?"
Die Therapeuten
sind eher wie die Architekten,
die das Haus
zusammen mit der Familie aufbauen.
In den letzten zehn Jahren
haben sich die Notfallzahlen
mehr als verzehnfacht.
Sie steigen nicht nur absolut,
sondern auch in Relation
zur Bevölkerung, Jahr für Jahr.
Mich beunruhigt das sehr,
dass die Notfallzahlen
in unserem Notfalldienst
sehr stark angestiegen sind.
Das hat einerseits etwas Positives,
dass immer mehr Jugendliche in
der Krise unsere Hilfe auch suchen.
Andererseits ist es aber auch Aus-
druck einer allgemeinen Jugendkrise,
dass der Leistungsdruck
und der Druck durch Vergleiche
in sozialen Medien gestiegen ist.
Und sich immer mehr Jugendliche
selbst gefährden durch Suizidalität,
durch sich selbst ritzen usw.
Wie ist es mit dem Drang,
dich selbst zu verletzen?
Er ist kleiner.
Es waren immer Leute anwesend.
Ich tu es nicht, wenn Leute da sind.
Ja, okay.
Wenn du nochmals den Drang bekommst,
dir selbst wehzutun,
dich mit der Schere zu ritzen,
kannst du dich 24 Std. am Tag,
sieben Tage die Woche
bei uns melden.
Das ist mir sehr, sehr wichtig,
bevor du eine Dummheit begehst.
(Pauli) Die ersten Anzeichen
sind oft ein Rückzug
aus dem Familienleben,
dass man die Jugendlichen
nicht mehr erreicht,
Eltern mit ihnen
nicht mehr ins Gespräch kommen.
Dass sie sich
von ihren Hobbys zurückziehen
die Lust an allen Aktivitäten
verlieren,
dass sie sich von ihren
gleichaltrigen Freunden zurückziehen
und da nichts mehr unternehmen.
Alarmstufe rot ist, wenn
suizidale Gedanken geäussert werden.
Wenn man sieht,
dass sie sich selbst verletzen
oder wenn sie gar nicht mehr
in die Schule gehen können.
Beni ist früher unterwegs
als an jedem anderen Morgen,
denn heute ist sein 18. Geburtstag
und seine Klasse hat ihm
eine Überraschung versprochen.
Um 3 Uhr bin ich mit einem
riesigen Lächeln aufgewacht.
Seitdem warte ich darauf,
in die Schule gehen zu können,
wo ich meine Freunde treffen kann.
Sonst habe ich nicht viel getan.
* Die Klassenkameraden singen
"Happy birthday to you". *
Hi!
# Joyeux anniversaire.
In der Klasse fühlte sich Beni
immer gut aufgehoben.
Dieser Rückhalt gab ihm auch
in der grössten Krise Sicherheit.
Ich weiss, niemand beurteilt mich,
niemand macht sich lustig über mich.
Ich weiss,
dass ich mich wohlfühlen kann
und dass niemand
etwas Schlimmes denkt,
weil ich über alle anderen
gleich denke.
Ich habe hier meinen Platz gefunden.
Wir sind wie ein Rad,
ich bin ein Teil davon,
und zusammen drehen wir.
Emil wohnt bei seinen Eltern.
Sein älteres Geschwister
ist bereits ausgezogen.
Emils Probleme machten auch
vor dem Elternhaus nicht Halt.
Mit Schulwechseln
versuchten die Eltern damals,
Ruhe in sein Leben zu bringen.
Ohne Erfolg.
Die Wut,
die er gegenüber Mitschülern hatte,
den Frust und alles,
hat er nicht dort abgeladen,
wo er es hätte abladen sollen, also
im Verständnis von uns Erwachsenen,
sondern eben zu Hause.
Und das hat das Geschwister
und uns Eltern sehr belastet.
Dem älteren Geschwister ging es
damals auch nicht wirklich gut.
Er war einfach auch sehr reizbar und
überhaupt nicht kooperativ und so.
Wie war das auszuhalten?
Das weiss ich bis heute nicht.
Ich habe nur noch funktioniert.
Ich habe geschaut, dass es
rundherum noch einigermassen geht.
Also ich habe nur noch funktioniert.
Ich bin arbeiten gegangen,
meine 60 %.
Ich habe zu Hause geschaut,
wie es machbar ist.
Manchmal ist Emil
dann auch mit ins Büro gekommen,
wenn ich wusste,
dass ich allein im Büro war,
dann wusste ich:
Er ist wenigstens bei mir.
Früher hatte ich
immer verdammt viel Stress.
Nach einem anstrengenden Schultag
bin ich am Mittag
vielleicht abgehauen.
Die Zeit um mich herum fühlte sich
an wie Karamell, megaklebrig.
Und alles fühlt sich
megakomisch an.
Und du willst ein bisschen Erlösung
von diesem unguten, stressigen
Gefühl, das du im Herzen hast.
Und bei mir
war es eben Selbstverletzung.
Da konnte ich
ein bisschen kompensieren.
Dann bist du so:
"Fuck! Warum habe ich das gemacht?"
Und: "Fuck! Meine Eltern haben mich
nicht auf die Welt gebracht,
damit ich mich selbst aufschneide."
"Fuck! Ich enttäusche wieder alle."
Dann fängst du wieder von vorne an.
Langfristig
ist es einfach keine gute Lösung.
Und ich empfehle es niemandem.
Es wäre schon schöner ohne Narben,
finde ich,
aber ich will sie im Moment
auch nicht weghaben,
weil sie für mich
Überbleibsel aus einem Kampf sind,
den ich gewonnen habe.
Ich bin schon ein bisschen stolz
drauf, dass ich es geschafft habe,
es nicht mehr zu machen und
aus dem ganzen Shit rauszukommen.
Mir würdest du sie mir zeigen?
Ja.
Darf ich sie mal sehen?
Dafür muss ich
meine Jacke ausziehen.
Die Schnitte auf der Arminnenseite
habe ich meist heimlich
in der Schule gemacht.
Wenn es megaschlimm war,
habe es zu Hause getan.
Hier versuchte ich,
eine Sehne anzuschneiden.
Hier oben habe ich noch eine,
das ist die Schlimmste,
die ist mega aufgeklafft.
Die bin ich auch
im Kinderspital nähen gegangen.
Wie lange ist das her?
Es ist sicher schon
ein halbes Jahr vergangen,
seit ich mich
das letzte Mal verletzt habe.
Es war schlimm.
Also v.a., als wir zum ersten Mal
notfallmässig
mit ihm zum Nähen gehen mussten.
Denn es war so tief, dass es anders
gar nicht mehr gegangen wäre.
Ich habe mir wirklich
sehr viel Mühe gegeben,
dass sie nichts davon mitbekommen,
weil ich sie auch
nicht verletzen wollte.
Ich wollte nicht, dass es
ihnen auch noch schlecht geht,
weil es mir schlecht geht.
Das wollte ich überhaupt nicht,
das hat mir überhaupt nicht gepasst.
Aber Eltern sind eben Eltern
und finden es schon raus,
wenn es ihrem Kind schlecht geht.
Meistens zumindest.
Der Familie steht ein Umzug bevor.
Die Siedlung
muss einem Neubau weichen.
Emil wird einiges hinter sich lassen.
Ich habe so viele Sachen
in diesem Haus gemacht
und Zeit in diesem Haus verbracht.
Ich finde es schon etwas schade,
es ist eben mein Kindheitshaus.
Aber ich freue mich auch
auf den neuen Ort:
neues Zimmer, alles etwas
anders. Das mag ich immer sehr.
* Schwebende Klänge *
Während Emil
allmählich zur Ruhe kommt,
stecken andere
noch mitten in der Krise.
Ein Montagmorgen im Dezember
in der Klinik für Kinder-
und Jugendpsychiatrie in Zürich.
Morgen miteinander.
Wie war die letzte Nacht?
Auf Station 1 hat eine Patientin
im Ausgang
einen Suizidversuch begangen.
Im Kispi wurde sie genäht
und kam dann zu uns.
Auf Station 2
hat eine Patientin an diesem Tag
sowohl den Suizidversuch
ihrer Freundin
auf dem Zimmer im Heim miterlebt
als auch den Suizidversuch
der eigenen Mutter am gleichen Tag.
Deswegen ist die Patientin
auch suizidal geworden
und wollte freiwillig
aufgenommen werden.
Ansonsten haben wir gestern im A0
eine Patientin
nach Suizidversuch aufgenommen.
Der andere ist der 18-Jährige?
Genau, der über 18 wollte
ins Kriseninterventionszentrum,
die haben ihn
gestern Nacht aber abgelehnt.
Da war der Vater
auch wirklich sehr enttäuscht.
Und da muss man sagen:
So geht es nicht mehr weiter.
Die rufen jedes Wochenende hier an.
Der Junge ist belastet,
hat immer wieder Krisen,
wird immer wieder suizidal
und droht mittlerweile den Eltern,
dass er sich umbringen wird.
Die Wochenenden sind häufig
sehr schwierig in der Psychiatrie.
So heftig wie dieses Wochenende
ist es eher selten.
Aber es kommt immer wieder vor,
dass sich Jugendliche auch
in der Klinik selbst verletzen
oder eben auch versuchen,
sich das Leben zu nehmen,
wenn sie wieder zu Hause sind,
in der gewohnten Umgebung.
Das stellt eine Überforderung dar.
Und dann ist es wichtig,
dass man eben schnell reagiert
und diesen Jugendlichen
wieder den notwendigen Schutz gibt.
Gefeit gegen Krisen ist niemand.
Ein bis zwei von zehn Jugendlichen
leiden unter psychischen
oder physischen Störungen,
die Fachleute auch als Folge
des erhöhten Erwartungsdrucks werten.
Das Beruhigende ist,
dass die Rate der
vollendeten Suizide im Jugendalter
nicht zugenommen hat.
Dafür gibt es mehr Phänomene von
Suizidalität und Selbstverletzungen.
Wir denken, es hat damit zu tun,
dass die Jugendlichen heutzutage
früher Hilfe suchen
und früher Hilfe bekommen.
Früher war das ein absolutes Tabu.
Da war jemand, der suizidal war,
ganz auf sich selbst gestellt.
Deshalb ist es wohl
eher dazu gekommen,
dass der Suizid
leider auch vollendet wird.
Seit einem Monat
ist es wirklich nicht mehr gut.
Ich bin nicht mehr ich selbst.
Ich mache Dinge, die nicht gut sind.
Wie z.B. Alkohol trinken,
rauchen, ritzen.
Ich bin auch sehr offen
beim Thema Tod.
(Weinend) Entschuldigung.
Macht gar nichts.
Ich kann nicht mal einen Punkt
nennen, der mich wirklich betrifft.
Ich weiss einfach,
dass ich einen mega Selbsthass habe,
und ich kann einfach nicht mehr.
Kannst du dich daran erinnern,
wann das angefangen hat?
Anfang Oberstufe?
Oder wann hat das angefangen?
Der Selbsthass hat
in der fünften Klasse angefangen.
Okay.
Ist da irgendetwas vorgefallen?
Im Klassenlager haben die Jungs
eine Schönheitsliste gemacht,
auf der ich
auf dem letzten Platz war.
Und das hat mir gezeigt:
Ich bin nicht schön.
Und wenn ich dann
etwas nicht geschafft habe,
dann habe ich mich dafür bestraft.
Wie hast du es gemacht?
In der ersten Sekundarschule
habe ich mit Ritzen begonnen.
Ich hörte damit wieder auf,
weil ich nicht wollte,
dass andere sehen,
dass es mir nicht gut geht.
Dann habe ich mich gekniffen
oder an den Haaren gerissen.
Dieses Jahr
begann ich wieder mit Ritzen.
Mittlerweile ritze ich mich
täglich an den Beinen.
Ich will nicht,
dass man es an den Armen sieht.
Wenn du dich ritzt, was gibt dir
das? Was ist für dich positiv daran?
Ich spüre den Schmerz,
merke, dass ich noch lebe.
Gab es Phasen, in denen du
ernsthaft darüber nachgedacht hast,
dir etwas anzutun?
- Letzten Dezember.
Als du das erste Mal
zusammengebrochen bist.
Ja, ich war ein paarmal betrunken
und fand:
"Jetzt hole ich mir Medikamente
und dann ist gut."
Was hält dich
im Moment noch am Leben?
Ich bringe mich bewusst nicht um,
weil ich weiss,
dass es Leute in meinem Leben gibt,
die mich lieb haben.
Ich würde sie damit nur zerstören,
und das will ich nicht.
Während eineinhalb Jahren
hatte Beni regelmässig
Psychotherapiestunden besucht.
Seine Krise,
die ihren Höhepunkt in Depressionen,
Suizidgedanken
und einer Essstörung gefunden hatte,
überwand er mehr und mehr.
Den ersten Teil der Matura
hatte er hinter sich.
Beni fühlte sich stabil.
Da erreichte ihn die Nachricht, sein
Vater sei einem Herzinfarkt erlegen.
In der Schule waren wirklich
gerade alle Prüfungen vorbei:
Maturaarbeit, Bio,
alles Schlimme war vorbei.
Danach hätte ich
eigentlich Ferien gehabt.
Es hat sich so angefühlt,
als hätte mir das Leben
das auch noch eingebrockt.
Aber es war wie ...
Es hat mich mega stark gemacht.
All meine anderen Probleme
wurden plötzlich ...
Wie von selbst
wurden die vielen Probleme weniger,
weil ich mich nicht mehr
auf meinen Vater verlassen konnte,
dass ich gesünder werde.
Ich musste mich
auf mich selbst verlassen.
Es hat mich gestärkt, weil ...
Nach dem ursprünglichen Schock
war ich einfach so bereit,
auch so pragmatisch und parat,
um alles durchzustehen.
Und ich habe nicht mehr geweint.
Von diesem Abend an ...
Bis ich wieder einmal allein war
und wirklich Zeit für mich hatte.
Und dann ist es plötzlich
einfach aus mir herausgebrochen.
Die letzten 5 Std.
sind einfach aus mir rausgekommen.
Meinen Geschwistern erschien ich
stark, obwohl ich der Jüngste war.
Aber in diesem Moment
war ich plötzlich so erwachsen.
So responsible.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Seither ist alles anders.
Plötzlich muss ich
alles selbst bezahlen.
Die Wohnsituation ändert sich.
Es war heftig,
was das alles ausgelöst hat.
* Sanfte Ballade: "What A Wonderful
World" von Louis Armstrong *
# I see friends shaking hands
saying how do you do.
# They're really saying:
"I love you".
# I hear babies crying,
I watch them grow.
# They'll learn much more
than I'll never know.
# And I think to myself:
"What a wonderful world."
Er wusste eigentlich immer,
dass er sich auf seine Familie
und seine Freunde verlassen konnte,
auch wenn er es
zwischendurch vergessen hat.
Und jetzt z.B. auch ...
In den paar Monaten
nach dem Tod des Vaters,
als wir plötzlich
sehr viele Dinge annehmen mussten,
die zuvor einfach
für uns erledigt wurden,
da habe ich an ihm bemerkt,
dass es Momente gegeben hat,
in denen er zu mir gekommen ist
und gesagt hat:
"Seren, ich kann das alles nicht.
Kannst du mir bitte helfen?"
Und eine Woche später
hat es ihn genervt,
dass ich überhaupt da war.
Und dann wollte er
wieder alles allein regeln.
* Fetziger Popsong:
"Money, Money, Money" von ABBA *
# Money, money, money.
# Must be funny.
# In the rich man's world.
So wie er sich auf der Bühne
präsentiert, das fasst ihn zusammen.
Diese Seite hat ihn auch immer
wieder aus dem Loch reissen können.
Eigentlich ist er in meinen Augen
eine sprudelige Persönlichkeit.
Er ist einer derjenigen, die am
meisten Leidenschaft, Hingabe haben.
Er besitzt einfach
eine unglaubliche Hingabe
an die Musik, ans Tanzen
und an das alles.
* Popsong: "Man in the Mirror"
von Michael Jackson *
# If you want to make the world
a better place.
# take a look at yourself,
and make a ...
# If you want to make the world
a better place.
# take a look at yourself,
and make a change.
Yeah, much better.
Everybody clap,
everybody move at the same time!
Beni möchte seine Leidenschaft
zum Beruf machen.
Deshalb bewarb er sich
an der Stage School in Hamburg.
Seit er
aus den Sommerferien zurück ist
und in Hamburg
an der Musical-Schule war,
ist er energetisch neu geboren.
Er hat eine wahnsinnige Energie.
Und v.a. auch so eine Unbedingtheit,
wie er Dinge angeht, durchzieht,
auch in diesem Projekt:
Wirklich scheissegal, was rechts
und links ist, was für Stimmungen,
er zieht sein Ding durch.
Er muss nicht cool sein,
sondern er zieht es einfach durch.
Ich glaube, da hat er
sehr Feuer gefangen, wirklich.
Tata, ta, tata.
Ta, tata, ta, ta. Taataa.
Trotz Erkältung und Fieber -
the show must go on.
Eine Bühnenprobe
lässt Beni nicht ausfallen.
Wie hat es sich angefühlt
dort oben auf der Bühne?
Nicht so geil wie sonst.
Warum?
Weil ich gemerkt habe,
dass ich fast umgekippt wäre.
Aber so grundsätzlich
ist dort schon dein Platz?
Der Mittelpunkt
ist immer mein Platz.
* Fetziger Popsong: "Valerie"
von Amy Winehouse *
# Stop making a fool out of me.
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
* Reggae-Song:
"Bongo Bong" von Manu Chao *
# 'Cause I'm the king of bongo.
Ich wusste lange auch nicht,
dass ich gay bin.
Wir sind alle sehr sensible Seelen.
Von Anfang an
war es herzlich und aufgeschlossen.
Da war dieser Zusammenhalt, voll.
Wir lernten,
über unsere Differenzen zu reden,
ohne dass jemand beleidigt ist.
Ich merke,
dass sie mein Seelenpflaster sind.
Sie fangen mich auf, wenn ich falle,
und schauen, dass es mir gut geht.
Und das ist
eine megaschöne Erfahrung.
Emil lernte Juno und Beda
in der Klinik kennen.
Seit einem Jahr
sind die drei befreundet.
Wir haben uns einen Ort ausgesucht,
wo wir unser kleines Universum
aufbauen können,
wo wir einfach sein können,
ohne über den Alltagsstress
nachdenken zu müssen.
Spürt ihr einen Anpassungsdruck?
Ja, das spürt man wirklich.
Man spürt es wirklich von aussen.
Auch auf den sozialen Medien usw.
ist es wirklich so,
dass alle gleich aussehen.
Mich stört, wenn mir Leute,
die mir nicht nahestehen, sagen:
"He, du hast abgenommen." Ja.
Okay,
vielleicht ist es ein Kompliment.
Aber war ich vorher fett?
Habe ich nicht so ausgesehen,
wie ich aussehen sollte?
Warum merkst du,
dass ich abgenommen habe?
Das ist doch nicht dein Business.
Konzentrier dich doch auf anderes!
Frag mich, wie es mir geht,
wie ich fühle, was ich denke!
Ich habe realisiert,
dass die Leute nicht wahrnehmen,
wie es mir geht
und wie sie mit mir umgehen sollen.
Ich kann es verstehen, denn für
andere Leute ist es nicht einfach,
mit solchen Menschen umzugehen.
Sie sollten achtgeben, ihnen kein
schlechtes Gewissen zu bereiten.
Wie hat sich Emil verändert,
seit ihr ihn kennt?
Früher hatte ich das Gefühl,
ich rede gegen eine Wand, manchmal.
Nicht immer, aber manchmal
hat es bei ihm einfach zugemacht.
Dann ist nichts mehr gegangen.
Das Kindliche eben.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
du hast in der Therapie gelernt,
wie du diesem Verhalten, wenn du
in sozialen Situationen bist,
weniger Platz gibst.
Und dass du die Situation
von aussen betrachtest,
und denkst: "He, ich nehme mich
mal ein wenig zurück."
Und du kannst auch
besser Kritik annehmen.
Du hast auch gelernt,
dir nicht immer alles
so mega stark zu Herzen zu nehmen
und in dich hinein zu fressen.
Du hast immer
den schlechten Aspekt angeschaut.
Und ich denke,
in dem Jahr, seit wir uns kennen,
hast du megastark daran gearbeitet.
Man sieht dich auch
einiges öfter lachen.
Ein richtiges Lachen.
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
* Tragende Klaviermusik *
Als kleiner Junge hatte Beni während
zwei Jahren Ballettstunden besucht.
Seit der bestandenen Aufnahmeprüfung
an der Musical-Schule in Hamburg
nimmt er wieder Unterricht.
* Klavierversion von "What A Feeling"
von Irene Cara *
Wie hattet ihr das geübt?
In den letzten Jahren
ist er ruhiger geworden.
Er hat sich selbst gefunden
mit dem Tanzen, dem Singen.
Er ist nicht mehr so konzentriert
darüber, was andere denken.
Alle aus meiner Klasse
sind mega darum bemüht,
was sie in Zukunft tun.
Sie sind mega gestresst davon,
Bene überhaupt nicht.
Er weiss, was er macht, er hat die
Perspektive mit der Musical School.
Deshalb geht es ihm auch besser.
Und jeder
hat mal seine schlechten Tage.
Es ist früher Morgen auf Station 1
in der Klinik
für Jugendpsychiatrie in Zürich.
Kann ich dir das geben?
Muss ich mir Sorgen machen?
Nein, ist okay.
- Bring es nachher wieder zurück!
Eine enge Begleitung durch
Fachleute aus Medizin und Pflege
gibt Sicherheit.
Auch auf den stationären Abteilungen
steigen die Zahlen
der Hospitalisierungen Jahr für Jahr.
Anders als auf den Kinderstationen
sind bei den Jugendlichen
mehrheitlich Mädchen platziert.
Jede Patientin
bekommt ein individuelles Programm.
Zum Essen trifft man sich.
Auch der streng reglementierte
Klinikalltag hilft dabei,
die Krise zu überwinden.
Wir denken,
dass die Jugendlichen heutzutage
mit Suizidalität
und Selbstverletzung versuchen,
auf eine nicht funktionierende Art
ihre Probleme zu lösen.
Sie erhoffen sich eine Besserung.
Viele wollen ja nicht sterben,
sie wollen einfach
nicht mehr so weiterleben.
Emil war zweimal
in der Kindertagesklinik.
Kurze Zeit auch stationär.
In dieser Zeit führte er Tagebuch.
Ich habe mich
sehr oft mit anderen Sachen
als mit Schlafen beschäftigt.
Wenn es mir nicht gut ging,
schlief ich selten gut.
Hier: wie ich
auf der Schulbank einschlafe.
Das ist oft passiert.
Was warst du für einer,
als du hier angekommen bist?
Ein junger, sehr unsicherer Bub.
Sehr unzufrieden mit sich selber.
Da hatte ich schon Angst:
"Was kommt da auf mich zu?"
"Was verlangen die alles von mir?"
"Was muss ich alles machen,
damit es gut wird?"
Haben sich
diese Befürchtungen bewahrheitet?
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Es war immer sehr offen und man
konnte wirklich über alles reden.
Man konnte sagen: "Mir geht es
heute nicht gut, es läuft nicht."
Und das war okay.
Das habe ich ziemlich cool gefunden.
Nach zwei Monaten in der Tagesklinik
stand erstmals ein Austritt an.
Auf die Euphorie folgte Panik.
Da ging es mir wirklich nicht gut,
sondern wirklich beschissen.
Obwohl ich entlastet wurde, war
trotzdem immer noch alles zu viel.
Ich konnte nicht mehr für
meine eigene Sicherheit garantieren.
Wir fanden, wir können das
jetzt zu Hause nicht tragen.
In der Nacht.
Das konnten wir
nicht mehr verantworten.
Sie hatten Angst, dass er
sich etwas antun könnte? - Ja.
Obwohl Sie da waren?
- Ja.
Hat er das so klar geäussert?
Manchmal ja.
Dass er nicht mehr leben will?
- Das Schlimmste war, als er sagte:
"Euch würd's doch allen besser
gehen, wenn ich nicht mehr da wäre."
Das hat er oft gesagt.
Noch am Tag des Austritts kam Emil
als Notfall zurück in die Klinik.
Zu seiner Sicherheit auch über Nacht.
Ich wurde von meinen
eigenen Gefühlen überrollt.
Die ganzen aufgestauten Emotionen
haben mich umgeworfen.
Es war schlimm, v.a. für mich,
aber für meine Eltern
wahrscheinlich auch ein wenig.
Was machte dir Probleme?
Der Stress eben: daran denken,
was ich alles machen muss,
was alles wieder auf mich zukommt,
wenn ich zurück in der Schule bin.
Dass ich dann viel mehr machen muss
und die Belastung
wieder viel grösser ist.
Ich bin damit
einfach nicht klargekommen.
Was ich anders machen würde?
Ich würde es
nicht so lange geheim halten.
Das hat alles nur schlimmer gemacht.
Wir können wirklich vielen helfen.
In dem Alter ist es schon so:
Jugendliche sind noch nicht
fertig in ihrer Identitätsbildung.
Und wenn sie dann
die Unterstützung bekommen,
die Jugendlichen und die Familien -
wir beraten ja auch die Eltern,
die auch mithelfen können -,
dann können wir
wirklich sehr, sehr vielen helfen,
damit sie wieder
aus der Krise herausfinden.
Jetzt geht es mir super.
Ich mache die Matura fertig, dann
gehe ich nach Hamburg studieren.
Für meine nächsten fünf Jahre
ist jetzt festgelegt,
was ich machen werde.
Und ich hatte gestern zufällig meine
letzte offizielle Therapiestunde.
Ich und meine Psychologin
haben eigentlich beide festgestellt,
dass es mir super geht und ich
gar keine Therapie mehr benötige.
Ich habe in den letzten Monaten
immer wieder kurze Krisen erlebt
und eigentlich gerade danach
selbst gewusst, was zu machen war.
5 Min. hatte ich ein Down,
wusste aber genau, was machen,
das habe ich
in den letzten Jahren gelernt.
Und ich weiss genau: Ich werde
jetzt aus allen Krisen herausfinden.
So stelle ich es mir vor.
Warum?
Weil ich einfach stark genug bin.
Weil ich jetzt mein ganzes Leben
lang trainiert habe, stark zu sein.
Und jetzt endlich finde ich:
"Jetzt ist gut. Jetzt habe ich es
langsam herausgefunden."
* Imposante klassische Musik *
* 1. Klavierkonzert Nr. 1 op. 11
von Frederic Chopin *
Emil ist unterdessen 15 geworden
und am neuen Ort angekommen.
Auch er sieht
voller Zuversicht in die Zukunft.
Ich will Chemie studieren
und deswegen eine Lehre
als Chemielaborant machen.
Chemie ist das einzige Schulfach,
das meine Faulheit überwunden hat.
Es macht mir Spass.
Ich kann beginnen,
meine Umwelt zu verstehen,
zu verstehen, wie alles funktioniert
und warum es funktioniert.
Das finde ich megatoll.
Ich liebe es, herumzuschauen
und wenigstens einen Bruchteil
dessen zu verstehen, was abgeht.
Es ist so überwältigend.
Ich habe mehr Methoden gelernt,
mit mir selber umzugehen,
als ich gelernt hätte, wenn ich
nie in eine Klinik gegangen wäre.
Ich durfte mich selbst kennenlernen
und ich durfte selbst einsehen,
dass es okay ist,
wenn man nicht perfekt ist,
dass es okay ist, wenn man nicht
alles kann, was die anderen können.
Und das ist mega wertvoll für mich.
Das habe ich gebraucht.
Und ich bin froh,
dass ich das jetzt so habe.
Was für eine Herausforderung,
in der Pubertät sich selbst
und seinen Platz
in der Gesellschaft zu finden.
Dass dies nicht auf Anhieb gelingt,
ist nachvollziehbar.
Dass es ohne Druck besser geht,
ebenfalls.